over the next 5 10 and 20 years there
are going to be developments at the
intersection of
biology and technology that will present
us with some of the most profound and
vexing choices our species has ever
faced
the tools of genetic engineering and
synthetic biology
are giving us unimaginable powers and we
have even more capabilities coming down
the pike
that are going to completely transform
our species what i really want to talk
about is
design and what we're moving into is the
phase of biological design that
we've only imagined in science fiction
i'm going to start with bowen zhao
he wants to design custom microbiomes
because
he understands that the microbiome
is the source of disease and so if we
can
understand that we can diagnose and
predict many uh chronic metabolic
diseases
he's also excuse me interested in
creating a whole new class of
pharmaceuticals
that would be based on the chemicals
produced by microbes metabolic processes
this is steve ramirez his technology is
based
on infusing the brain's neurons with a
particular
light sensitive protein that makes it
possible to either activate or
deactivate
certain cells with pulses of light so he
basically uses optogenetics
to erase specific memories in mouse
brains
he can erase those memories he can
enhance the memories or diminish the
memories
he can even install new memories that
the mouse never had before
his work has profound implications
for humans of the future then there's
george church
also featured in our book george is
probably the most inventive bioengineer
of our times
he's maintaining this list i think
there's about 50 alleles and genes on
here
to enhance humans ccr5 for hiv
protection
has also been shown to have cognitive
benefits
there's a grin 2b gene which is
associated with learning and memory but
there's a whole other list of edits
that we could make to prepare humans for
space travel
so that might include lrp5
which gives you extra strong bones or
there's four different mutations
combined
that can increase your resistance to
radiation or you might simply use
pre-implantation genetic screening to
find the embryos that are
going to be selected for small stature
which would be helpful if you're crammed
inside a tiny little space capsule
danny hillis wrote a fiction piece based
on the actual science
where the couple walk in and have a
consultation with
a genetic counselor in the future he
talks about the fact that
you know your children may find extra
appendages very useful
people get excited about tails they have
their pluses and minuses
but you know additional appendages could
be quite
handy and then he goes through a series
of accessories
and add-ons and basically upsells the
genetic counselor might try and uh
convince you to go for he talks about
aesthetics and how
parents could get suckered into or
trapped into something that's
a little too trendy that just feels
outmoded 10 or 15 years later but oh
bubber
you've been genetically designed to
express that
feature david eagleman has a piece in
our book
about the possible remorse we may have
as parents for some of these choices